I know like there's a lot of marriage
with there is no sex involved and it's
normal but
that's
that's our people they are different
like well my whole point is that like as
the women we in that deal it's not a
fair deal because we get the protection
and provisioning and the long-term
commitment which is what we want right I
mean unless you marry the guy that you
know assuming you don't marry a guy
that's gonna run right but the men it's
like the most important thing that men
want
is defend the girl over backwards you
know what I mean and so it's like they
don't even they don't even get that out
of it and so it's like it's like the
number one thing that they want we can't
even give them so it almost becomes an
unfair deal because these guys get
married and they're thinking dang I get
this unlimited sex with my wife and then
she's like nah I got the kids I'm good